the images you are seeing right now have
been a closely guarded secret for years
this is the first time footage of this
technology has been shared publicly
a technology that has the potential to
change the course of human history
privilege helion energy granted us when
we visited their facility what I am
sharing right now is going to be studied
by nuclear physicists around the world
trying to reverse engineer the world's
changing machine
this is Trenta helion's sixth generation
nuclear fusion generator this fusion
generator is unlike any other using a
completely novel approach to achieve
nuclear fusion adapting knowledge
developed for ION propulsion in Space
the generator forms two mirrored rings
of Plasma on either end of a reactor and
in a tenth of a thousandth of a second
they fire them at each other
sequentially activating powerful magnets
to squeeze and compress the Rings
towards the center where they Collide
converting the astonishing kinetic
energy of the ions traveling at 300
kilometers per second into thermal
energy raising the plasma temperature to
tens of millions of degrees hot enough
to overcome the electromagnetic
repulsion keeping the ions apart and
allowing them to fuse forming new atoms
and releasing a tremendous amount of
energy in the process
this isn't the world of fairy tale this
is already happening I watched the
bright pink flash of fusion multiple
times inside the control room of Trenta
safe away from the gigawatts of power
surging through the capacitor banks of
the reactor it became mundane pretty
quickly to the point that my reaction to
the feast became oddly subdued
but make no mistake what helion has
achieved here is astonishing initiating
nuclear fusion reactions with ease so
let's jump into it with helion's
brilliant founder David Curley giving us
the world's first tour of Trenta
so yeah can you just like start
explaining
what this machine is yes so you're at
helion's Redmond facility
um here we're staying in front of our
sixth generation machine we call this
one Trenta this is the sixth generation
of machines that form merge and
compression compressed Fusion plasmas
diffusion conditions doing Fusion like
we're looking at
this end of the machine but it's
mirrored on that end can you explain
like why you do the pulse reaction
towards each other yeah it's a great
question
um the fundamental concept of how these
systems work is unlike most fusion and
here we inject a fusion Target we call
this one a field reverse configuration
then using pulsed magnetic fields to
very high pressures we compress that
fusion plasma up to Fusion conditions
one of the challenging Parts is how do
you get that Target that initial Fusion
fuel into the compression chamber and do
it in a repeatable symmetric
um uh high energy way and so one of the
things that we pioneered was a concept
of merging field reverse configurations
merging these plasmas where on we
actually have a symmetry on either side
of the machine we have these injectors
we call them the formation section where
we actually form this initial plasma we
inject the Fusion fuel we then
accelerate them merge them in the center
region where they take all that kinetic
energy that we put into them when we
accelerated them and they stop they
stagnate inverting that kinetic energy
into temperature into thermal energy and
that starts the fusion reaction we then
can compress it all the way up to the
full Fusion conditions okay and the
actual
plasma generation happens on this end
right the plasma generation happens
right here interestingly enough so over
here we're standing in front of what is
called the diverter this is what happens
after the reaction here is our formation
section here is where we initially
inject our neutral gas so the gas is
ejected from a flow manifold a fuel
manifold here where we puff in gas in a
neutral gas that's just at room
temperature this gas fills this chamber
over the course of several thousandths
of a second at this point it's room
temperature it's very low pressure a
Fusion fuel mix of deuterium and
helium-3
we then ionize that gas what that means
is we start to heat that with a
combination of RF and electric fields
which then take the electrons that are
orbiting the nucleus and tears them off
of the nucleus forming a plasma charged
particles positive and negative charges
in this area
we then form what is called a field
reverse configuration where what we do
is we take magnetic field that's keeping
this plasma this part it's ionized it's
for us relatively cool it's about a
million degrees but that's still so hot
that it can't touch any of the walls
without damaging materials so to prevent
that we have magnetic fields that thread
through this entire machine keeping that
hot fuel that hot Fusion fuel plasma off
of the walls but what we do here which
is quite unique is that we then take
that initial magnetic field and by by
pulsing at very high intensity over a
hundred thousand amps per coil we then
reverse that magnetic field trapping
magnetic energy in a closed field this
is called a self-confined self-organized
plasma
it's a really unique version of of
Fusion fuel that that healing on and
very few others do but what that enables
us to do is form a closed magnetic
topology a closed plasma object that we
can do things to we can actually do work
on
um and so at that point we now have a
closed field reverse configuration in
this formation section we then start to
pulse these magnetic field coils at high
at high pressure sequencing them and
they get sequenced as we go down we call
that peristaltic acceleration like
squeezing a tube of toothpaste it
accelerates that plasma out of the
formation section which had all the
complex ionization gas injection and all
those things into higher Field section
at this point we've now moved into what
we call the acceleration section or the
plasma injector where literally here we
are now continuing to accelerate this
plasma to over a million miles an hour
300 kilometers a second and higher down
down the the length of the system but as
we do that we start to compress it
already so as we increase the magnetic
field through adiabatic compression
ideal gas law as you increase the
magnetic pressure the plasma then
compresses decreasing in radius but
increasing in pressure and temperature
so as it's left the formation it's it's
on the order of several million degrees
but now we start to compress it we start
to accelerate it and if we've done
everything right and sequence these in
just the right way this plasma field
reverse configuration has now
accelerated all the way to 300
kilometers a second it's heated to on
the order of 10 million degrees and then
we we um we inject it into the main
compression section you notice here the
bolts the pressure everything goes up
because here's where we really do the
fusion if we've done everything right
this FRC this that we've injected into
the main compression section has met its
mate that we made symmetrically on the
other side and what they do is those two
Collide those two plasms Collide and
here's a really important part they stop
they stagnate they take all that kinetic
energy we added all that velocity and we
turn that into thermal energy it super
heats up and if you've done everything
right in the middle of this you have a
system that's on the order of 10 to 20
million degrees sitting in this main
compression section ready to do Fusion
so now you rapidly as fast as modern
technology will allow we increase the
magnetic field to high pressure
compressing that fusion plasma all the
way up to Fusion conditions over 100
million degrees Fusion starts diffusion
begins large amount of fusion is
happening inside this core compressed
FRC now
his core compressed Fusion fuel the
fusion reactions start to occur those
Fusion reactions are creating new
particles deuterium fusing together with
helium-3 to form helium-4 and an extra
hydrogen and both of those two particles
are very high temperature now they're
born inside the fusion plasma applying
pressure back on these magnetic fields
that works just like in a piston or in a
piston you compress the fusion you
compress the fuel it begins to burn it
then gets hotter it pushes back on that
piston only we do it all
electromagnetically this is a truly
Innovative concept with Tokamak reactors
like the massive eater reactor being
built in France right now electricity is
created by converting the kinetic energy
of neutrons expelled during Fusion to
heat by slowing them down in the blanket
walls this heat is then transferred to
high pressure water to create high
pressure steam which turns the turbine
attached to an electric generator that
rapidly rotates the magnetic field
around copper wires to generate an
electric current helion is skipping
steps one through four and going
straight to moving a magnetic field
around copper wires generating
electricity directly from the magnetic
field cradling the fusion reaction at
the center of the machine as the fusion
reaction occurs the energy it generates
begins to push back on the magnetic
field confining it moving it as David
said like a piston it's this changing
magnetic field that will generate
helion's electricity skipping all the
initial steps needed to boil water and
turn a turbine should in theory make it
vastly more efficient while also
unlocking the major benefits of a
superior nuclear fusion fuel mixture one
of the problems with Tokamak reactors is
their choice of fuels the fuel mixture
of choice for tokamax is deuterium and
tritium the availability of deuterium is
not a problem it's everywhere this is a
bottle of heavy water water with two
deuterium atoms instead of two regular
hydrogen atoms cheap and safe I can even
drink it however tritium as we spoke
about in more detail in our last video
is extremely rare we only have about 20
kilograms of it in global reserves and a
single commercial scale tokemak is
expected to burn through 300 grams of it
a day giving us about two months of
operation with the world's entire
current Supply Tokamak generators will
manufacture tritium on site using a
lithium breeding layer when the high
energy neutrons from our nuclear fusion
reaction collide with the lithium in the
reactor wall the lithium splits into
tritium and helium this is a reasonable
solution but eighty percent of the
energy of the tritium deuterium fusion
reaction is carried by those high energy
neutrons so we have effectively wasted
all of our energy to get back to square
one to combat this the first layer of
Tokamak walls will be made of beryllium
a neutron multiplier which creates two
neutrons when struck by one Neutron
giving us one Neutron to create tritium
and one Neutron to generate Heats
however beryllium is extremely expensive
the entire annual Global Supply is just
enough to build a single Tokamak
generator beryllium also contains
uranium impurities which will be
encountering the high energy neutrons
too making the beryllium blanket
dangerously radioactive over time which
will make disposing of it expensive this
all points to one massive problem
Tokamak reactors are going to face the
exact same issues as nuclear fission
energy they will be too expensive and
won't be able to compete with cheaper
forms of electricity this is why helion
is using a completely different fuel
mixture
so helion's approach diffusion use a
deuterium and a helium-3 fuel deuterium
is really common it's part one part and
500 in all water it's in the coffee
drink and safe and and and readily
abundant and low cost as well we buy it
in uh Compressed Gas cylinders it's
already purified but you could imagine
doing the purification yourself it's
pretty straightforward the helium-3
however is ultra rare and in fact while
helium-3 was theorized in the early days
of fusion as being the best Fusion fuel
because of its Rarity there haven't been
a lot of approaches that have used few
helium-3 or demonstrated helium-3 to our
knowledge Trenta was the first system we
know about that did bulk helium
deuterium helium-3 Fusion for a power
generation application one thing Elion
has done is we patented uh helium-3
process of creating helium-3 I'm taking
two deuteriums found commonly in nature
and a high pressure infusion system
ironically fusing them together to form
helium-3 taking one more deuterium
fusing that with the helium-3 to make
helium 4 and that make that's what makes
electricity so it's only the reaction of
deuterium with helium-3 that generates
the
deuterium with deuterium generates some
amount of electricity a small amount it
generates about
um 1 8 of the of the deuterium helium-3
reaction
what influences that so it influences
the amount of power output per reaction
is is the actual Atomic physics that's
happening where when two deuteriums
combine they have a few reactions but
the one we care about most will create a
helium-3 and that that helium-3 will
have a lower Mass deficit so the amount
of missing mass of that that final
product so E equals MC squared and that
mass deficit is the amount of energy
that's released in terms of the
particles that are created and their
temperatures and so deuterium helium-3
has a larger Mass deficit when it forms
helium-4 and so you end up with more
energy trapped in that that helium four
as well as in the other proton that is
made
there's quite a lot to break down there
as David said the energy released
depends on the mass difference in the
final reaction but how we can capture
that energy changes with the products
that are created too two types of fusion
can occur when fusing two deuterium
atoms one creates a helium-3 atom and a
neutron most of the energy of that
Fusion event is carried away by that
Neutron Tokamak reactors generate
electricity by converting the kinetic
energy of neutrons to heat in their
walls but helion's energy capture system
can't generate electricity with neutrons
because they have no charge
helion needs charged particles to push
back against the magnetic confinement to
generate electricity that Neutron just
flies right through the magnetic jail
the helium-3 however carries about 0.82
Mega electron volts of useful energy
that the generator can capture in a
second possible reaction deuteriums can
create a proton and a tritium with the
proton carrying 3.2 Mega electron volts
of energy and the tritium isotope
carrying 1.01 helion's generator will
capture as much energy as possible from
these particles before exhausting them
through the turbo molecular pump in the
diverter section with the protons
regaining an electron and becoming
hydrogen and the radioactive tritium
being transferred to remote storage here
it will beta Decay into helium-3 plus
this process takes 12.3 years to occur
when it finally does Decay that helium-3
can be fed back into a generator so
helion has two Pathways to create
helium-3 for their primary Fusion energy
reaction when deuterium and helium-3
combine they create a helium-4 atom and
a proton releasing 18.3 Mega electron
volts more than the 17.6 Mega electron
volts released from deuterium and
tritium reactions and on a mass basis
four times more than a uranium fission
reaction being able to generate your
fuel right where you need it is a huge
Advantage Plus David curtley had an
interesting alternative
[Music]
um it's a very good business case of you
could do it that way or you could do it
where you have one dedicated facility
and all it does is fuse deuterium and
make Fuel and then put it in a bottle
separate it from all the other the other
gases and then ship that to your
generators and have the generators just
make electricity and not deal with the
fuel processing I think that's a good
outstanding business decision that we we
don't know one of the things that you
have to keep in mind is when you do the
deuterium Fusion that's when you make
the neutrons so the neutrons come from
the deuterium deuterium fusing together
and so there's some really maybe
advantageous things of separating those
two machines one of those advantages is
prolonging the life of our generator the
high energy neutrons from the deuterium
deuterium reaction can damage our
generator this is a huge problem for
Tokamak generators because 80 percent of
the energy in the deuterium tritium
reaction is carried by the neutron but
the neutron generated when two deuterium
item's fuse as five times less energy
reducing the damage it can do however
they are still damaging if we could
design a cheaper more robust reactor
purely to create our fuel products that
could be economically beneficial
especially if there are multiple
generators that all need fuel supplies
replacing one fuel generator that can
feed 10 energy generators is a lot
cheaper than replacing 10 Hybrid fuel
and energy generators
so there are many benefits from moving
away from deuterium and tritium but the
deuterium and helium-3 reaction does
require higher temperatures and this
does pose an engineering challenge
especially as helium progresses to their
commercial scale reactor
so right now we're building Polaris
their seventh generation system the goal
is that it will demonstrate electricity
production for the first time come
online in 2024. the the stepping stone
between our seventh generation system
we're building Polaris and the eighth
generation system is a lot of the
engineering around the system that we
want to turn up the power output the
yield even further we want to make sure
we're taking that electricity that we're
recharging capacitors with turning that
into 60 hertz AC and putting that on on
the grid and then also repetition rate
that's a big one is that going from
operating every few seconds to now
operating multiple times a seconds is
another engineering jump leap we have to
make in some of the thermal engineering
structural engineering and gas Handling
Systems what do you think is going to be
the biggest challenge in making that
jump I think any if you ask any engineer
or scientist on my team you're actually
going to hear a different answer for
what is the hardest thing that we're
trying to solve my personal belief in in
building the steady operating systems
that we built in the past is it comes in
into the thermal operation of these
systems whereas things start to heat up
they change the structural mechanics
change of these pulse magnets uh the way
the fusion plasma actually the wall
temperature changes as it changes in
temperature we saw that on our earlier
subscale systems and so we expect to see
that on the big scale systems too and so
understanding that predicting that and
then engineering all the mechanisms in
place for that I think are going to be
some of the most exciting engineering
challenges that we're solving right now
and so we're hiring those teams to to to
solve those problems right now were
there any surprising learning moments
recently that you've discovered with
trying to there were some exciting
things that we learned on Twitter that
were unexpected we were really worried
early that the timing accuracies of
merging these two high-speed plus was
over a million miles an hour compressing
them working on getting their alignment
um that that would be really a tough
Challenge and what we found that is in
practice is actually quite a bit easier
than the theory or the basic computation
simulations would actually show that we
can with a lot of essentially Freedom
merge these and get really good results
that are really repeatable
some of the things we did find however
that are a little bit more challenging
is as these plasmas got hotter and we
got above 10 million degrees and got to
the 100 million degrees what we found is
that there's probably some other effects
good effects where we're producing more
Fusion than we maybe predicted but the
fusion plasma interacts with the vacuum
chamber a little bit more than what we
thought as well and so what we're having
to do for future systems is build them
just a little bit bigger about 25 bigger
than what we'd originally planned to
account for those things and so there's
some engineering iteration that has to
happen as we discover the the advanced
physics and and the engineering of
implementing these systems in practice
this is another one of the benefits of
helion system it's a much smaller
generator than other generators like
eaters tokomak which makes iteration far
easier as larger machines will be more
expensive to build making the capital
cost of learning a much larger barrier
Polaris is their seventh generation
system and its 25 percent bigger
precisely because of the lessons learned
from Trenta the physics of fusion is a
new frontier there are a few textbooks
to learn from helion is helping write
the first textbooks and one of the
things they discovered is that gyro
orbits are larger than they expected a
gyro orbit is essentially the radius at
which those fuel ions orbit around
magnetic field lines it's affected by
the temperature and thus the speed of
the ions and the magnetic field strength
helion discovered with Trenta that these
orbits are larger than simulations
calculated which meant the ions could
impact the generator walls and given
their temperatures this was a no-go so
Polaris is 25 percent larger to account
for this discovery Polaris will also be
the first generation to begin capturing
electricity but that's a lot easier said
than done and will need the very latest
Electronics to work quickly enough under
Trenta there are Stacks upon stacks of
capacitor Banks ninety percent of
trenta's power goes towards generating
the huge currents needed to generate its
magnetic fields the magnets that form
and push the plasma forward run at 100
000 amps while the main compression
coils at the center of the machine run
at 1 million amps
drawing that kind of current from the
grid is impossible so Trenta needs a way
to store power locally and discharge it
quickly to achieve the necessary current
batteries can't discharge that quickly
so helion is relying on capacitor Banks
we took a look beneath Trenta to learn
more about them so what you're seeing
here this is actually one capacitor unit
and so if you're used to other
electronics each of these boxes is one
unit each of those boxes is one
capacitor that has several kilojoules
worth of energy storage in it and then
we have hundreds of those capacitors
that all in parallel in a modular way
make the main bank
I'm in parallel to that are other
capacitors that are slower response
higher efficiency those are run with
semiconductor switches
um and then even some capacitors that
are very old
um that are maybe 20 plus years old that
we use for some of the formation
sections some of the injector the
initial ionization sections
any issue with them being older is that
just like
the length of time you've been working
on this technology you just had these
line about or is it better to use newer
um it depends so what we've seen is over
the years the way the pulse power
technology and Community has evolved
some of these capacitors are actually
still the highest performing
capacitors because the industry doesn't
manufacture a lot of these for our type
of application now one thing you'll see
later in in our facility Antares
facility in Everett is our new capacitor
manufacturing line where we're making
custom capacitors designed for exactly
this application and those outperform
even the older technology
is there any issue with just the rate
that when you get up to faster pulses
that these might deteriorate over time
or yeah so one one of the keys to these
systems is as you're running them what
we call repetition rate where you're
pulsing not once every 10 minutes like
Trenta does but we're you're pulsing
every 10 seconds or once a second or ten
times a second now the lifetime of the
capacitors their ability to handle
throughput average throughput and the
heating in the capacitor starts to
become engineering issues that we have
to consider
luckily as we've evolved so has the
capacitor technology and so self-healing
and other capacitors that have long life
maybe not pulsed but are long life those
capacitor Technologies are now enabling
for us to to do this on subscale systems
not on trento but Trenta has done over
10 000 high power pulses doing fusion
and some of our subscale systems that we
did earlier that weren't doing Fusion
but we're making these types of plasmas
we've done not not tens of thousands but
we've done billions of discharges with
capacitors and run them steady for
months on end at hundreds of Hertz so we
have a lot of experience in building
steady operating pulse Power Systems
that are quite a bit smaller than this
and so a lot of the work we have now is
taking those experiences and that
engineering experience that we have at
helion and gr and combining that with
the large-scale pulse power Fusion
systems and merging those two together
into the Polaris system
with the size of this capacitor Bank you
would think it holds an astounding
amount of energy but the total capacity
of the bank is just 10 million joules
the equivalent energy of about 22
bananas or in terms of a typical Tesla
battery pack that's 2.8 kilowatt hours
130th the capacity of a typical Tesla
battery however we aren't expending that
energy in an hour we were releasing it
in 100 microseconds these capacitors
release a lightning bolt of current
through the machine gigawatts of
instantaneous power but it isn't an
uncontrolled burst of electricity like a
lightning bolt it's a carefully
controlled Orchestra of switches
releasing and controlling this much
electricity with the micro second
Precision simply was not possible when
the concept was first envisioned within
those 100 microseconds thousands of
operations occur across the machine each
row of electromagnets along the machine
need to activate 300 nanoseconds after
the previous they need to trigger just
as the plasma passes by traveling at
millions of kilometers per hour to push
it even faster towards the center that
would be impossible without modern day
microprocessors and fiber optics
and even then helion needs to factor in
the speed of light through the glass
fibrous the time it takes for a current
to propagate through a tiny
semiconductor switch and account for
every other delay in the system Legacy
Electronics simply have two wide margins
of error to account for those delays
properly without fiber optics those
millions of amps traveling through the
system would induce currents in other
parts of the machine and create misfires
what helion is doing right now is
astounding the sequence of events to
cause Fusion in this machine is a
delicate Symphony of electronics pushing
two plasma Rings into a violent
collision and catching that Collision in
a magnetic trap in the center which
proceeds to shrink until the ions
trapped within it have nowhere else to
go but to fuse overcoming one of the
universe's strongest forces to create
new elements in the belly of a man-made
machine but helion isn't done they are
already building the next step in their
quest for Clean safe energy for
humankind with their seventh generation
machine which will do everything Trenta
can do but faster and add another
process capturing the energy of the
expanding plasma to generate electricity
adding even more complexity to the
delicate symphony with the energy
flowing back and forth from capacitor
Banks like the top hides on ashore and
hopefully if all goes according to plan
each turning of the tides will push a
world-changing electricity Source onto
our grids I have never been particularly
hopeful that nuclear fusion power was
ever feasible but speaking with David
and all of The Talented staff at helion
and the recent news from the U.S
department of energy about their net
energy output from their inertial
confinement reactor it has really made
me feel that this technology may not
just be possible but potentially around
the corner we shot hours of footage at
helion and cutting it down into a
cohesive and entertaining YouTube video
went through a lot of interesting
information was left out it would be a
shame for those interviews to be stored
on our internal servers never seen the
light of day so I have made two of the
longest interviews available to watch
for our nebula subscribers which you can
get access to with an even lower price
due to our 42 percent holiday discount
giving you the nebula and curiosity
stream bundle deal for just 11.59 for
the entire year less than one dollar a
month for Access for yourself or you
could buy it as a gift for the holidays
the full Encore tour of Trenta
understanding interview with David
curtley are both available on nebula
right now we are aiming to do many more
documentaries like this in 2023 visiting
companies working on radical new
technologies and interviewing their
engineers and we simply would not have
the budget to fund a production like
this without nebula our spin launch
documentary which occurred over multiple
days and in two different states
requiring gear rental hotels camera
operators editors animators and more
ended up costing around thirty thousand
dollars to make a price we simply could
not afford without your support on
nebula so as thanks we will be uploading
behind the scenes footage that did not
make the cut to nebula for any shoots
like this going forward along with their
original series like the logistics of
D-Day and the Battle of Britain
[Music]